you know isn't it funny to me i it's
it's this very strange thing that
happens again and again and again where
i'm taking and you're such a good
example of it nikki where
what are the things you fear you fear
um
criticism yes you feel someone saying
something to you that's going to be
hurtful
um
there is a side of you that just wants
to go and and probably
um be in a room where you don't have to
deal with anyone who might be unpleasant
or hurtful and what do you do
you become a stand-up performer
and you are out there all the time
that is this weird duality that
fascinates me me too because i i know it
all too well and i have proof which is i
have a letter i wrote to the author eb
white in 1980 when i was what 17 16
and i wrote on this letter and i said
i'm really interested in
writing and trying to creative stuff but
i'm just so afraid of criticism and then
what do i do i'll replace letterman from
obscurity
i'm sure though you know and i knew i i
so why do we seek out the thing that we
most fear and relive it again and again
and again i think we're trying to
prove the thing we think about ourselves
wrong you know like we're trying to we
think we're inherently not really that
funny or entertaining or deserving of
love so we are trying to prove that
wrong to ourselves by doing the thing
that will if we achieve enough we'll be
convinced of it which is another paradox
because no amount of adoration or a
claim i mean i i can't speak for you but
i always feel like i'm just tricking
everyone i mean imposter syndrome which
is a common topic for any performer to
struggle with but
but why and i think there's something
about stand up for me though that
it's not interactive i if you listen to
my standup i rarely have any kind of
lull i do not like a lull ever um i
don't take my time i'm so scared i'll
get heckled
you're not funny
you suck
like i i used to like you i had one guy
at a show say i used to like you we i
was a fan this sucks i like had a pence
reference during you know it was right
before the 2020 election and it just
triggered him so that was what that was
but man that was my biggest fear i used
to
that just sets me off
i hate that
yeah i try never to talk about um trump
on stage because i don't want to know
who likes him because i don't want to
resent any parts of my audience and so i
just don't want to know if i don't hear
someone laugh at a cert so i try not to
but there was just some reference about
you know i was talking about in high
school i didn't kiss a boy
until i was like 17. i i was a prude
like i was scared of boys because my mom
told me my mom's sex talk for me was
that like if you're ever alone with a
boy they'll
rape you essentially is what she said to
me like just to scare me that was her
bedtime story
now good night click
you don't look like you slept much last
night nick what happened cause dad tried
to come in and tell me a story after you
mom
uh
yeah i was terrified of boys and so i
just compared myself to um
because it was true i never was alone
with a boy in a room all through high
school i was i said i was like the mike
pence of my graduating class like i
wouldn't share a room with the opposite
sex and if i did i'd have to go tell
mother and that's all i said but this
guy got up and in the middle of the show
i used to like i i believed in you and
that was even worse to me than he just
was it mike
[Laughter]
i loved you he doesn't stand up for
anything
i just like pence likes your earliest
early really dirty stuff
you're a hunk about your vagina was
fantastic
but what is this why did you bring me
into it it's it is that it's that it's
like
that's why i i just um
joke i can't ever have any time where
there's they're just listening to me
without
without a laugh because i need constant
validation like okay i still have them i
still have them i i watch chappelle or
these comedians that can take their time
and really just like walk you you know
even watching norm especially on your
show just being able to just
walk you through and and have patience
with you becoming uh bored almost right
right boy i can't do that
well the panic you know the other thing
is
i'm going to jump in like i'm your
therapist and say please you're saying
you can't do it you can do it yes you
can do it and um
you aren't
funny
uh because you move because you're so
well defended that's not what makes you
funny it you're that's well it's true
well what don't you think that we are
funny because we are we are defending
ourselves well what i'm saying is
whatever
i think there are plenty of things that
go into the mix and most of it happened
early on
i think the ingredients that anyone
needs to be funny usually come fairly
early in life and then they have them
and then their big fear is they're going
to lose them
but i've watched so many people who i
really admire that have gone through you
know they've been in fashion they've
been out of fashion but they're just
always really funny to me they have that
great rhythm
and they try different styles i promise
you as your friend i promise you you do
not you don't need to change a thing
but
you can breathe into it more because
you've earned the right you know you've
been around for a while and you've
really you've paid your dues and you're
really funny and people know who you are
and yeah people come and go i'm sure
i've
shed fans that liked me in the 90s and
then there are people that i've had
people that really have told me pretty
much
i really wasn't into you at all but now
i like the podcast and i'm
very cruel to them they should be
they're wrong
they're wrong no no no but for whatever
reason for whatever reason i used to
hear something like that and it was like
a poison pill or a thorn under your skin
and then later on you
as you go on you just i don't know you
just realize uh i
i don't have the energy to hang on to
that kind of stuff anymore it's too
exhausting so i do think
you've at this point in your career and
in your life you've
earned the right to not be on stage
thinking i've got to get through this so
no one screams you suck yes and also i
would point out if you were doing your
sat and someone screamed out at you you
suck and everyone heard it
you would be so funny yes it would be
the highlight of the show because then
the rage comes out but also because
they're wrong and you would have fun the
voice that uh you know earlier in my
career someone shouted out you suck it
had the ring of
well they might be right there's such
good chance they're right and that's the
terror yes but when you know they're
wrong yeah you know or they're not
specific i would i would say to someone
who yelled out at me
i yes i do suck but in what specific
ways you better have the because there
are specific ways in which i suck you
know yeah i think i was kidding there
really aren't no there's a lot why did
everyone go with that
yeah
no one saw this but uh girly just
produced a santa claus list that
unfolded and it's it's rolling down
three flights of stairs and out onto
larchmont boulevard
and it's still going people are adding
to the list on the street right now
there's a huge
the list is now reaching the continent
of asia it's reached the sh it's gone
across the pacific well let's get
started all right let's go through cbs
receipt yeah but anyway
when are you going to be done with that